how much you're making off those two now
then it's a profit or if some of you
haven't got any houses yet but you
qualify by being here you are property
investors now so you can just tell the
world I'm a property investor because
like but how many houses do you own you
have it and it's like hey I'm just
getting started
this is new I only finished the crash
course yesterday but and there's gonna
be people that say oh you know sweet
girls that do the Academy and stuff and
you know after three minutes people are
gonna say you're a millionaire ya don't
have those people in your life there's
two types of people that build or a
person is terrorist animus there's
people that want to see you do well and
there's people that do not want to see
you well my rule is I don't hang around
people that don't want to see me do well
because they're no good I only want to
hang around with people that want to see
me do well I don't know what it is in in
in the UK and brand because in America
you see someone driving a Ferrari 250
thousand pound car in America you're
like hey what do you do good for you see
the same car in in Britain true or true
the mindset is not wanting to see people
do well whether that be jealousy
whether that's we trying to protect its
people whether I don't know what it is
but what I say is walk run from those
people run from those people don't try
and change them don't try and win them
over
I've got a really my best friend you
know my best friend doesn't really
support me on my property they think
it's a bit scary and they start the
other you know tell me what's your
advice how can I persuade them mm-hm
find a new best friend that's my advice
how many you know what was my rage and
say yes so and in the same way some of
this stuff that I'm teaching you today
some of this stuff no-money-down stuff
it freaks people's brains and I just
don't get it that I happen you buy a
house with no money how can they don't
get it the good thing is the very first
skill that you need is you need to be
able to find the deals you can all find
the deals you can do it
and I'm really impressed and I spoke to
Alistair spoke to Ricky like you
honestly you guys this this room is a
very very smart room very very good
rooms because the deals and the energy
and the success already I mean people
would be
doing people a bit I've been hearing all
these stories did the lady who's the
lady just got to regiment deals this
shirt has surely smoking up the lady's
good just got a second when two men deal
at the bat is that you did you already
stand up here and tell the story you
already did tell me that cuz of my head
i selfish the woman oh what's your name
or what happened hey
[Applause]
nobody does I never got the double life
Idol it so I just wanna learn inside
yes oh yeah there's some crazy people
here yeah how much you're making off
those two now there is a profit or what
about the first one how much you make in
the man so you're financially free
[Applause]
what's your background what did you do
before property good for you
what was what was your strongest reason
why did you get what did you want to
start a property that's not bad date why
do you want to get rich yeah
what will you do when you stop when you
when you start making it you know when
you start getting this income from
property you have more time what's more
we gonna do things good beautiful person
I taught my dc1 winners Wednesday the
next few months I'll see you I'll talk
to him even if you haven't already give
her a hand awesome awesome looking
awesome and the fact that we support the
fact that we support you in that and
you've got like a few hundred people
that like yeah well done that is called
rare because on Monday that will not
probably be the case on Monday over like
Oh sounds risky
Oh like that so I would urge you guys to
get in this kind of environment as often
as possible
because when you've got people around
you that want you to do well the effect
of that that that's a massive part of
success that make sense yes or not let's
get to this how many down deals that
lady I think I don't even remember that
lady's name I'm sure we're gonna become
super good friends but here's the thing
she wants to help her mom what does she
do
me from you and I don't know you
watching this video but I tell you
something she took massive action
she had big energy and she went on the
trainer program it's really really smart
and she have a really good wealthy
background I don't know maybe not I'm
not that smart
I'm not going to wealthy background me
and that lady what we had in common was
we took action we took the step and we
went on the training programs listen I
always bad when I become wealthy I'm
gonna be generous and only mother in
Genesis one money which I am I have a
charity and different things I'm also
gonna be generous with my knowledge I
put three videos out every day on
YouTube
I put three training programs on I have
a crash course I run the crash course
I don't need to run the crash course I
want it for free I even get hate from
running it because people like annoyed
with me sharing these principles and
stuff or skeptical it's just crazy but
I'm gonna keep doing it let me tell you
something you want to get the same kind
of results you want to become
financially free you want to help your
parents your kids your family you want
to live with purpose you want to have an
edit extraordinary life you've got to
take action you've got to take the
training so get yourself booked on from
the property investor scratch course
I'll be there I'm gonna be running the
crash course and over the next few
months so book on you can get a ticket
right here there's the ticket thank you
for watching my videos I appreciate your
support if you're not subscribed
subscribe over here but you know what
you're not going to get rich watching
YouTube come on the crash course I look
for to seeing you there it's free on the
house